you don't have to like my blog but it's
the only one that's like it as opposed
to trying to make it like everybody else
and that's what we do for a living we
tell stories not slogans story patience
is for the impatient who picks average
who picks mediocre nobody we got Google
we got Facebook we've got eBay we got
Amazon none of them spend any money on
advertising there's a way you're going
to get what you want or cause the change
that you want to change to happen is
you're gonna figure out a way to get
your ideas to spread if you can get the
first two breaths over with you're going
to get the balloon filled up because
it's downhill from there just like
skiing the goal is not to get to the
bottom of the hill the goal is to have a
bunch of good runs before the Sun sets
the challenge that entrepreneurs have I
think is to stop looking for someone
with a rule book consumers don't care
about you at all they just don't care
he's an American author entrepreneur
marketer and public speaker he's the
author of 17 books tribes and linchpin
are his two best-selling books his blog
is considered to be the number one blog
in the marketing space according to
adage power he's Seth Godin and here his
top 10 rules for success
you know I started my blog about five
years ago if you type stuff into Google
you'll find it and along the way people
said why don't you have Twitter why
don't you have video why don't you have
a podcast why don't you have comments
why don't you have this why don't you
and there's lots of things I could have
done and if I had done those things I
wouldn't have had at the blog I have
today but by saying this is all I'm
willing to do it's going to be just this
once a day me and my voice and I'm not
going to pay attention to the way other
people are telling me a blog is supposed
to be you don't have to like my blog but
it's the only one that's like it as
opposed to trying to make it like
everybody else how many people visit
your blog more than I can count
I actually don't spend a lot of time
looking at the numbers because then I
spend all my time trying to make the
numbers go up and my goal isn't to have
the most popular blog my goal is that my
blog to be whatever I needed to be in
that moment and so I've forced myself
not to study the stats I do know
Technorati says I'm the 12th most
popular blog in the world which is fine
and it's growing but what I'm really
focused on is what kind of email do I
get do I get an email from people who
say yeah look at your blog every once in
a while or during an email from people
say I've been reading it for six weeks
and look what I changed in my life thank
you for inspiring me to do that and
that's what gets me out of bed to do it
every day I love going to farmers
markets and if you go to the farmers
market and this guy's got better
strawberries and this guy because he's
using less of something in it he'll tell
you the details but no one's waiting
there because this guy's got a cuter
sign because this guy's telling a story
that's resonating with me and that's
what we do for a living we tell stories
not slogans stories little red
riding-hood is a story once you've heard
it you're going to remember it for your
whole life and it's something that
resonates and that it matches the way we
want to see the world so when we see a
kid with a lemonade stand it's different
than when we see a vending machine
selling lemonade even if it's exactly
the same product because the story
around it is what people are paying for
so when I meet small business people all
I ask them is not what's their balance
sheet but what's their story why should
I pick you why do I care about what
you're doing and if you start giving me
all this inside baseball statistics
about why you're two percent better than
some other competitor
I'm already glazed over because that's
not part of the way I see the world
patience is for the impatient that in
fact when you're getting started in your
in-laws are making faces at you and
you're not sure if you're going to be
able to pay the rent and you don't know
why you're living in Brooklyn to begin
with and you're going to have to move
back to Florida
it's easy to say you know what I need to
go faster to pick up these scraps to
pick up these scraps and sometimes what
that does is it gives you the foot up to
get to the next level but sometimes what
that does is it just makes your scrap
collector and that one of the things
that we see when we look at the work of
people who have put really big ideas
into the world who have built online
platforms right is that they got there
by being patiently impatient or
impatiently patient whichever way you
want to juxtapose it that if you look
around at the blog's you read or the
people you respect online or the
organizations you want to work with them
of the overnight success is just that a
myth that you know the much-vaunted
Twitter was a failure a complete failure
for two years nobody used it and if they
took the mindset of well if it doesn't
work in two weeks we got to go do
something else you never would have
heard of it
mediocrity is very common it means being
average average people are average
mediocrity is for losers the reason
mediocrity is for losers is given the
choice of five places to eat lunch are
you going to pick the mediocre one given
the choice of five people to hire are
you going to pick the mediocre one in
fact in our Google fueled world where
you have a choice of a million things
for every topic who picks average who
picks mediocre nobody so as a
salesperson you have a big problem
because there's all this pressure on you
to be average all this pressure to have
a bigger kickback selling more items all
this pressure to call on more and more
people offering them more and more to
fit in to wear the same clothes every
other salesperson to show up the same
ways every salesperson make the same
pitch and be cheaper and guess what
nobody wins a cheaper except for maybe
Walmart that the big win is when you
refuse to settle for average or mediocre
and you say I'm going to give up 90% of
what I could do and here's an example if
I go to yahoo.com there's a hundred
fifty links on that one page a couple
years ago if I went to google.com two or
three so Google lost all the
opportunities to drive people to finance
to drive people to weather to drive
people to this drive people to that and
instead they did one thing and so if
someone's at worst I searched even
though the searches were very similar
everyone said go to Google because they
stood out as opposed to be in the middle
and I talked about this a little bit in
Purple Cow but this takes it further in
Purple Cow I said the only way to win is
to be talked about because you can't
advertise you where you can't spam your
way you can't call your way into a
presence you get there could by people
talk about you but no one talks about I
know it's really average carpeting
salesmen never write what they talk
about is the barefoot carpeting salesman
who doesn't wear shoes and here's why
and let me tell you about what happened
when I bought something Baba and that
spreads the word so what we grew up with
was Mad Men Mad Men was advertising in
getting with the same thing if you spend
enough money on advertising you would
succeed but now that's over
so what we're left with is the product
is the marketing look we've got Google
we got Facebook we've got eBay
we got Amazon none of them spend any
money on advertising they spend all
their money on making something people
will talk about so if you think about
the Leaning Tower of Pisa now they
didn't make it lean on purpose but if
you ever go to Pisa there's tons of
tourists there because if you see the
Leaning Tower you can talk about it when
you go home right well it doesn't matter
that just a hundred miles away is the
Parthenon which is one of the most
beautiful buildings in the world it's
subtle it's not easy to talk about so
the question is are you going to build
something that is interesting
that's Leaning Tower of Pisa are you
going to make a product or service that
when people are done using it they can't
help but tell their friends about this
guy Dan Otto rohwedder invented sliced
bread and he focused like most inventors
did on the patent part and the making
part and the thing about the invention
of sliced bread is this that for the
first 15 years after sliced bread was
available no one bought it no one knew
about it it was a complete and total
failure and the reason is that until
wonder came along and figured out how to
spread the idea of sliced bread no one
wanted it that the success of sliced
bread like the success of almost
everything we've been talking about at
this conference is not always about what
the patent is like or what the factory
is like it's about can you get your idea
to spread or not and I think that the
way you're going to get what you want or
cause the change that you want to change
to happen is you're going to figure out
a way to get your ideas to spread and it
doesn't matter to me whether you're
running a coffee shop or intellectual or
you're in business or flying hot-air
balloons I think that all this stuff
applies to everybody regardless of what
we do that what we are living in is a
century of idea diffusion that people
who can spread ideas regardless of what
those ideas are when I was never good at
this and the reason I was never good at
this is it turns out if you've ever
tried it
that the first couple breaths are really
hard getting started is the opposite of
the plunger getting started with this is
really hard but if you do the physics
after the first two breaths the
percentage change in latex that you're
making gets smaller and smaller and
smaller with each breath and that the
model is if you can get the first two
breaths over with you're going to get
the balloon filled up because it's
downhill from there
so the way I look at the resistance even
before I knew what it was called is
pretty straightforward
if I'm going to do the first two breaths
I'm going to finish it so I'm really
obsessively careful about what I decide
to do the first two breaths about
because I know that if I start it then
it's all downhill I'm gone I'm going to
ship so I thrash at the beginning at the
beginning there's lots and lots and lots
of argument and discussion with lizard
brain lots and lots and lots of thinking
and scenario planning that says wait a
minute if I do these first two breaths
if I start thinking about a cover or a
thesis or whatever I'm going to finish
it so I better decide now the end result
is you get a lot of spare time on your
hands because you're not resisting
you're not delaying you're not saying oh
I need to see this next episode of Mad
Men because there might be something
useful in it for the next thing I'm
going to write you don't have that
conversation because you're already over
the first two breaths that it's all
downhill from there there isn't just one
dip get hurt it's not like let's get
through that dip and we're done Steve
Jobs helped invent the personal computer
helped launch the graphical interface
helped launch the mp3 business helped
launch computer animation at Pixar he's
not done right the point is just like
skiing the goal is not to get to the
bottom of the hill the goal is to have a
bunch of good runs before the Sun sets
and so what great sales people do is not
get to one dip and say I'm done I'm
going to the beach they look for the
next dip because that's all life is is a
series of dips that's why we're here to
go through the dips you know the facts
are facts
in the last 25 years the number of jobs
created by the fortune 500 is zero big
companies don't create jobs we know this
big government doesn't pay attention to
that because they're financed by big
corporations but what we know is that
our future is being described and built
by entrepreneurs the challenge that
entrepreneurs have I think is to stop
looking for someone with a rule book
stop looking for some franchise or
how-to book or dummies guide say send me
this money do this you will succeed
because that's not where growth comes
from that's being a pawn in somebody
else's game what I'm arguing for is
doing the hard work of being original
and the difficult work of navigating
without a map because if you do that
that is when you earn money and when
you've created value consumers don't
care about you at all they just don't
care part of the reason is they got way
more choices than they used to and way
less time and in a world where we have
too many choices and too little time the
obvious thing to do is just ignore stuff
and my powerbal here is you're driving
down the road and you see a cow and you
keep driving because you've seen cows
before cows are invisible cows are
boring who's going to stop and pull over
there oh look a cow nobody
but if the cow was purple isn't that a
great special effect I could do that
again if you wanted if the cow was
purple you notice it for a while I mean
if all cows are purple and you get bored
with those too
what marketers used to do is make
average products for average people
that's what mass marketing is the thing
that's going to decide what gets talked
about what gets done what gets changed
what gets purchased what gets built is
is it remarkable and remarkable is a
really cool word because we think it
just means neat but it also means worth
making a remark about and that is the
essence of where idea diffusion is going
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Chris seven eight to
zero
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leaving the comments below see what
I can do
I'd also love to know which of Seth
Godin top ten rules had the biggest
impact on you leave it in the comments
and I'll join the discussion thank you
so much for watching continue to believe
and I'll see you soon
it's really painful to be in business
you know you've got everything at stake
you got your reputation at stake and
it's just not working and we fall into
these traps of being impatient of being
self-absorbed and of being selfish we
say oh I bought this ad so I have the
right to put it in front of you we say I
only have three weeks to make my
marketing campaign work well if you
really needed it to work in the next
three weeks you needed to start two
years ago and we get self-absorbed we
say to ourselves I understand my
business I'm in in it every day
so I'm going to assume everyone else
understands my business as opposed to
taking a step back and realizing no one
owes you their attention and no one owes
you their money and so when we bring you
Millett II and generosity and clarity to
the way we do business all the mistakes
go away what you do for a living if
you're a salesperson is not take orders
because they can outsource that or put
it on the web what you do is a sales
person and not bother people into buying
from you because that's not a scalable
strategy what you do as a sales person
is you communicate emotion but you can't
communicate emotion and Trust to someone
if they're not listening and the only
people going to listen to you are the
people who are pre-sold on you because
someone told them about what you do and
how you do it organizations that want to
do marketing used to do marketing by
interrupting people they used to do it
by yelling at people who didn't want to
hear from them about stuff they didn't
want to hear about and they figured if
they just yelled it enough people often
enough they'd make enough money to earn
it back
small business is wrestled with this
because small businesses don't have
enough money to yell at everyone well
the world has changed pretty
dramatically we have discovered that
people don't pay attention to ads they
skip the ads they don't respond to the
as they'll remember the earth-boy the
Internet is doing is making it easier to
follow people you want to follow to
connect the people you want to connect
so the future of marketing it turns out
is leadership if you do something that
people want to follow if you connect
people to people they want to be
connected to they'll join a tribe or
group of people interested in
accomplishing something and if you can
lead a tribe then the marketing will
take care of itself
small businesses have a lot of
advantages here
biggest one is they're run by human
beings whereas big businesses are often
run by committees people don't want to
follow a committee they want to follow a
person and you must be genuine and
authentic in order to connect these
people and you have to care or else
they're going to set telling you you're
not so some big companies can certainly
do it
individuals conserving do it Oprah in
the United States does it all the time
coming like Apple which is the third
most valuable company in America right
now just past Walmart does it because
Steve Jobs appears to be a human being
because their products appear to be
designed by people for people when you
carry around your iPhone or whatever
it's a symbol to the other people in the
tribe and so this process does work it
works for B Cummings and for small ones
the beauty for small companies is that
tribes don't have to be very big to be
effective if you have a thousand true
fans thousand people who'll drive across
the country to see you perform thousand
people who will tell their friends
that's enough to make an impact